we checked with the American Civil
Liberties Union to find out if the city
can do what Burien has done make it
illegal to smell bad they make it their
business to mind your business parks may
become dog free zones in Durant Iowa
where many are fed up with owners who
don't scoop up after their pooches and
in Florida
it's illegal to sell craft beer in 64
ounce reusable growlers even though
customers prefer them to the 32 and 128
ounce growlers which are actually legal
but inconveniencing customers may have
been the point as the ban which is now
facing a legal challenge has long been
supported by beer companies that aren't
keen on the growing popularity of craft
beer it's time to put a stop to this but
your nanny of the month can be found in
Burien Washington where city officials
have banned Bo sort of occasionally
people will unfortunately have such a
bodily odor that it's very hard for
other patrons to physically be in that
same space according to new trespassing
law it's now illegal to smell bad in
public spaces like parks the library in
City Hall the ACLU thinks the law is too
big and gives police too much power to
decide who smells illegal some people
can be offended by other people's
perfumes although it's hard to believe
that a well-dressed middle class woman
is going to be booted out of library for
her perfume hey don't give the City
Council any ideas follow on Twitter
submit your nanny nominees and check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business
you